lourd dossier de la guerre en bosnie à
présent tous les regards sont tournés
vers londres et la réunion des grandes
puissances occidentales demain nous
allons y revenir mais sur le terrain
dans les enclaves musulmanes aucun répit
pour les habitants des milliers de
civils ont commencé de fuir la poche 2
est pas tombé hier soir aux mains des
serbes et les réfugiés continuent
d'affluer dans les camps de pouze la
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
dorothée olliéric et alain dumas
muratovic est un homme blessé
ils ne parlent pas ou peu mais accepte
de nous faire visiter son école il est
le directeur
et aujourd'hui il s'occupe
volontairement des quelques 800 réfugiés
de srebrenica qui ont trouvé ici maison
dans le petit village de gilles binet de
ces 2500 personnes ont trouvé un accueil
exceptionnel
bien sûr les conditions sont rudes mais
toute la population s'est mobilisée
chacun à sa passion tente de soulager
les douleurs des réfugiés ils ont tué
mes fils et mon mari
maintenant je suis tout seul c'est pas
ici qu'il faut finalement c'était là-bas
à très bonne et ça vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer ce que c'était moi j'aimerais
mieux être morte à les filmer autre
chose
mieux vaudrait nous tuer tous tout de
suite et les enfants aussi
qu'on en finisse avec tout ce malheur
ira tôt fitch le proviseur muré dans son
silence et sa souffrance sort de la
pièce
il a perdu le sommeil et peut-être aussi
l'espoir n'est pas la pudeur je
travaille ici comme garde la nuit
vous savez les réfugiés ne vendent pas
il sont assis à l'extérieur pendant
presque toute la nuit ils regardent ils
attendent les membres de leur famille
disparue il parle de toutes les
atrocités qu'ils ont vu et vécu
je crois que je vais devenir fou à force
d'entendre toutes ces histoires
ici pas de tente pas de nations unies
juste des bâtiments réquisitionnée par
le gouvernement bosniaque
des particuliers qui ont accueilli des
familles les bosniaques ont voulu
montrer qu'il pouvait se débrouiller
seul sans l'onu pour s'occuper de leurs
réfugiés mais ils manquent de tout et
sans l'aide de la population locale
difficiles il n'aurait pu survivre